so we're a few months away from the
final season of Game of Thrones I was
wondering if you could see into your
crystal ball and see what their
prediction will be for the final six
episodes oh man that is such that is
such a large question I think if what's
interesting at this point is they've is
they passed the books so so george RR
martin isn't completely driving the ship
yet if george RR martin if we're still
operating in the George RR Martin's
level I would say everyone would die I
think now I feel like since they passed
the books they've kind of clicked in to
a little bit more of a commercial like
commercially understandable type of a
story which means we're not gonna kill
everyone we love and so but at the same
time I think they're definitely gonna
surprise you it would it would be me I
definitely think I mean obviously you
know I think you know Jon Snow and and
you know Daenerys
I don't see them long term I don't see
them sort of both surviving I think it's
gonna be too easy for Daenerys to get
the throne I don't think they'll do that
because if I think they were going to
try to surprise this with something
different
I think that I think somebody will get
the throne that you don't expect whether
it's Tyrion whether it's Sansa something
like that will happen
which I think will be unexpected but it
but I think jon snow dies i my my
instinct is is that he dies I don't know
I mean it's just like they've they've
left it in such a such a wide open space
that I don't know exactly where they're
going with it I'm notoriously bad for
predicting things like this and but they
both what got me excited yeah I read
recently that they that they're they're
the battle that's sort of the big battle
that they have at the end of the season
they shot for 58 days straight just to
do one battle which makes me more
excited that I've never imagined so so
whatever it's going to be it's going to
be awesome
I I think I think I don't think the
White Walkers win I think we're safe I
think I'm safe to say that I think we
beat back the White Walkers in a way
that's that's unexpected but I still
think the White Walkers lose and then I
think how do they pick up the pieces
with the Seven Kingdoms I'm gonna go
with that the dark horse
Sansa gets the Iron Throne with Arya as
her hand with with either John or
Daenerys dying maybe even both so these
are these are my words not yours but are
they selling out then if they've gone
past the books and you say that george
RR martin is not fully driving the the
metaphorical ship sure how they sold out
I don't think so I mean like listen I
think if you can make people happy that
is the greatest achievement of an
entertainer like whatever whatever it is
is is there's this competition between
like between I can either make people
happy or preserve my artistic integrity
I think if that is what you're trying to
decide between there's something wrong
because the point of art is to have
people experience it in an amazing way
that the whole the whole thing is about
not just how do I create create
something how do I create something that
makes other people happy excited how do
I make people cry how do you make people
feel
that's the point and so if you make
something that people love and they
cheer and they're excited about and like
that's not selling out that's the point
of entertainment you've entertained them
in a way that they're happy I think
doing stuff like The Sopranos cutting
off the end and and it pisses everybody
off I am NOT a fan of that like I get
like sort of the we're gonna let you
finish the story in your mind that whole
thing I get I get all that but but at
the same time I look at I look at
entertainment very similar to
entrepreneurship like you you you were
you were there to serve something to
your fans that that gives them a
tremendous experience and if they walk
away pissed off and angry
then you've done something wrong not to
say they shouldn't walk away challenged
I'm a big fan of like challenging your
fan base I think that's what the last
Jedi did I think the last bait the last
Jedi challenge the Star Wars fan base in
a good way but but I think if they if I
think they'll go and they'll surprise
people I think I think but at the same
time I don't think they're gonna do
something weird to where you know they
they make it ambiguous I think it's
going to be clear I don't think it's
gonna be left up to interpretation I
don't think it's gonna be you know
something unsatisfying and awful that's
gonna like piss everybody off like
Joffrey comes back as a white Walker and
sits on the throne for the rest of like
eternity as like evil King Joffrey the
dead I think that would just piss
everybody off I don't think they're
gonna do anything at that but at the
same time I think they're gonna do
something unexpected so you know I don't
know like I'm all about Samwell Tarly
taking the iron throne oh that's cool or
maybe they make the iron throne
insignificant and you know I mean that I
think that would maybe thematically be
interesting because I think this sort of
the soap box of the guy of the of Game
of Thrones is all about
hey as we bicker over here amongst
ourselves there's something come to kill
us coming to kill us all and so we need
to unite and and and and you know stand
against that in that respect eventually
if like the game of throw the actual
iron throne becomes of zero importance
somatically maybe interesting to where
we now you know there's not one country
or not one place that rules the Seven
Kingdoms it's a different sort of a
setup I don't think they'll do that
because I think they only have six
episodes that's like a big restructuring
of the story your world but I'm for
Samwell Tarly surviving I'm four I think
are I think I think Arya well I think
Arya will finish her list I think that
Jamie is gonna kill Cersei and I think I
don't think Jon and Daenerys both
survive
pick one of the other and I think sons
if for the Iron Throne
that's my lock in Super Bowl prediction
you